שלום,
מר אליהו נאווי.
התאריך היום הוא יודע ל באבט אפשין
ביולי על. בשנת
הרעיון נערכים מר אליהו נהרי
הראיון נערך בביתו בגני אומר מראיינת ליפינסקי
מה ראוי, אני מודה לך שהסכמת,
היא
לספר לנו את סיפורך,
איך אותי לסמן בלוח.
ואנחנו נתחיל במשפחה בבית. בבקשה
יפה.
המשפחה שלי,
בוא הנה. המואר
במאה שמונה
היתה מן המנהיגות של יהודי
בפה
הרחם. אלו בנווי,
יהדות בבל. לא קראו הרב הגאון מרן.
חכם.
כן,
חכם ראובן. הוא היה
ראש הקהילה היהודית בבגדד.
חכם עלי, שהיה נאה. הוא היה
הרב הראשי של דארן, עסק,
אבי, עסק במסחר
ויהיה
בייגלה
בסערה.
מצרים
הודו
המסחר של
היא, אה,
גם בעסקי החליפין של מטבעות
וגם בארי.
הוא היה נשוי לאישה
שנה. היא לא ילדה.
ואז הוא לא כך. לא ילדה בת
האישה השניה. לא יהדות בבל מותר ריבוי נשים.
אני גדלתי בבית עם שתי נשים,
והיא הילדה הזאת, ילדה לו שישה
בנים
מוגבלים
ב
בארבע. חמש
היא הכינה לי. זה אארגן קבוצה
של עלייה
משיחי.
הוביל אותו הרב ניסים. לימים הרב
היה גם
חכם. סלמן אליה הוא אביו של הרב מרדכי אליהו,
והם ראו
בהצהרת דלפו חזרה על הצהרת
כורש
במינויו של הנציב העליון היהודי
אל בית סמואל.
כהמשך למינויו של השר לכימיה ונוכח עלייה מזעם מלך פרס
וכשאביא פעם סיפר לי את זה,
אז אמר לי תראה, אנחנו
גלינו עם
עגלות של בית ראשון,
יש שם בנו על נהרות בבל.
קצת. דחינו
קצת, אכלנו דגים
קצת, עשינו ביזנס, הפסדנו את הביתה שלי,
אנחנו לא רוצים להפסיד את הביתה השלישית.
והם הועלו. זו הייתה קבוצה מאוד מעניינת,
ביניהם אביו של יעקב נמרודי,
והגיעו לירושלים.
אבי הגיע
ב.
הוא
פתח
חנות של אריגים
בעיר העתיקה.
היה לו גם מחסן של אריגים בעיר העתיקה.
הוא שכר בית.
יש שתי משרתות
לכל אחת מהנשים.
המשרתת
רשם אותי לבית הספר,
ואחר כך שלך
שני מרצדסים
מירושלים לבגדאד כדי להביא אותנו.
כן,
זו הייתה עלייה של פעלה, נכון?
כמובן שבכל מרצדס לי הגבר מהמשפחה שלו, להשאיר
אנשים לבד.
מי היו אותי בבגדד?
אני לא זוכר הרבה, כאילו סגורים בבתים
ויהיה
לבית הספר.
היה לנו מה שנקרא אז בערבית חלפה
מלווה.
היינו איזה ארבעה חמישה ילדים בסביבה. היה במלווה מבית הספר. לוקח אותם.
מעורב בזה בסדר,
כדי שלא נלך לבד.
בבית הספר היה
ציוני
בשפה
הערבית
ערבית.
אני זוכר למשל בחגיגות פורמליות
אלה שומרים את התיק ב,
אבל האם יש שרים את זה עם עוד
נגינה?
וכל ארבעה
בתים
במקום ולפטם מזרח אמרנו אומרים
ולפטם. ערב
נעימה.
עוד לא אבדה תקוותנו.
התקווה הנושנה
לשוב לארץ אבותינו עיר, בדה והתחננה.
את זה שם במקהלה,
לעומת זאת,
תשאיר סעו ציונה, נס ודגל,
שאלנו בעמידת דום
בלי ערוץ,
אם כי נראה שבזה הם ראו יותר
את
המינון.
כשעלינו ארצה אספנו את כל משהו.
אפשר
את כל השטיחים,
את
כלי הכסף,
את המחט. אש הכבד שראית בחור, צאתה ששווה של אבא.
זה היה מקום
ונכנסנו לבית.
הוא רשם אותי לבית הספר.
איזה נאפולי אני הגעתי,
אני ירושלים,
הם עלו לירושלים. הם לא עלו לארץ ישראל
בגלל היית שניתן לדרוש,
יהיה והייתי בננה.
חמש שש.
לא היו לי בעיות של שפה,
כי הילדים בשכונה
דיברו ערבית,
ואני נכנסתי לשפה העברית. לאט
מגיעים לבית הספר
לרשום אותי.
אז המורה הרושם
שואל
מה שמו,
אז אני אומר חבר,
מה זה חבר
כל אחד מהם זה שמו של אבי.
אני סולח מן חודר
ראוי, והוא חודר בין סוילה
נאות.
אז זה אומר לא.
מה
הפירוש של חבר?
כלומר, חבר זה הירוק. ולפחות אליאס,
כך מכנים את אליהו הנביא אומר טוב, נקרא לו אליהו.
בסדר,
קראו לי אליהו,
שם משפחה, מה דעתך שנקרא לו מזה לוחם?
מה
אזרחי? בשום פנים ואופן. אבי לא רוצה לוותר על שם אביו,
אז התפשרו וקראו לי אליהו. חודרת
גם אליהו, השאירו את חאדר בצורה משובש
אנחנו
זה
אם היא ילדה שלושה בנים ושלוש בנות.
כאשר האמא
הצעירה שמחה,
אז אני נקראתי אליה או חודרי.
אך אם הוא שנקרא מושר סוילה
והחידוד נקרא גווין. מלאו
שלושה אחים
בשלושה שבועות
וייקח. למדנו,
יכול, למדתם
ודורש ציון וירושלים.
איזה בית ספר. מה זה היה?
זה היה בית ספר דתי
שייסדה האגודה של
זה נקרא, אמר חלים בפקידים מאמסטרדם.
בספר שנכנסתי אליו היה
ותק של מאה שנה
מהתלמידים שלמדו איתי
יצחק נבון
למבנה. שים את זה
עם
ישראל,
והחיים התנהלו
על מי מנוחות
עד
מאורות.
כעת, מה
מה עשה כאבא כשהוא הגיע למשחק
משרד, בעיקר בסחר הרגילים
ומורות.
שדדו לו את המחסן,
שדדו לו איזו חנות,
כולל ההצטברות,
והגיע
כשחזר לבי ולא הייתה
כל פרוץ.
מה זה לא כך? את המנעולים
שנשארו על הדלת
הם שמו לי ויסקי עד היום,
את המנעולים של הדלתות
ויהיה
ביטוח. לא היה.
אבי ירד
מן
הכוסות
לחלוטין,
והוא קורא יעשה כן.
ואז עברנו לגור בשטח בדרך
להמשיך בדרך. זה שכונה
יהודית ערבית
מעוררת,
אה,
ליד בנייני האומה
בירושלים,
כי שם שכר הדירה היה הרבה יותר זול
בשכנות. הייתי גל יצחק נבון.
אברהם דר
על ימים היה מרגיע מספר אחת של מדינת ישראל.
עקיבא עצמון, מפקד הנחה
שמילאה את כבישי הארץ וכלי תפוסים.
שמו היה עקיבא בהתאם ל
וגם בשכונה יהודית וערבית
מעורבת.
שם למדתי ערבית,
שיחקתי כדורגל יחד.
אבי התיידד, יימשך של נפטר,
והיו ביניהם שיחות כשיש, והוא מתאר את החנות שלי,
ערבי עמית.
את השם ספורות
שמעתי הרבה שנים לפני ששמעתי סוק רופס,
והיא הערבית. היתה לי הערבית הפלשתינאית.
הייתה לי
ספרתם שנייה.
אין לנו יחסים
טובים עם השכנים הערבים, אבל טובים ברמון. מוגבל
קהיר,
למשל.
הם היו בהם ממשתתפי מזמן, ומדורות לא ברור
ויהיה
השכנים נתנו רהיטים ישנים. עצים זה התמרור הענקי.
בשכונה שלנו גר, הציע
מאיר גורפיין המורים בבית הספר בצלאל ציור.
הוא הכין לנו
פעם
תמונה
הגדולה של היטלר.
הצבנו אותה בראש עמוד
במרכז המדורה.
אני רואה שיש אישית לא חשו אותו
בין הערביים.
הנערים הערבים, ואני שואל אותם מה זה
ומה
אתם שורפים. ערבי
לא ניתן לכם לסוף?
אז היית לערב זה גרמני.
זה לא ערבים
הגרמני בשיח
יש לו שפם. הוא ערבי. אתם לא תשרפו אותו.
ואז הורדנו את זאת.
הייתה תמונה
חוקים
ועובר הצייר.
הוא שואל מה זה? איפה התמונה? סיפרנו את הסיפור, אבל אין בעיות
מחק. לא את השפם.
ייצבנו אותו בליל עם תורה,
והכל בא על מקומו בשלום
אל
תחרויות
כדורגל בינינו לבין הערבים.
בחלק הראשון
הערבים שיחקו בצד היהודי. היהודים בסדר, אבל
במחצית השניה.
הערבים
היו בצד הערבי,
היהודים
בצד היהודי
והילדים התחילו לאסוף אבנים.
נגמר המשחק. התחילו
לזרוק אבנים זה על זה,
בלי שום קשר מיני. צ
לא בלי שום קשר. לא, זה היה זה טבעי.
ואחר כך הערבים היו שרים,
צועקים
יהודי, יהודי
או עיראק. קאבום. יהודי,
יהודי, יהודי ביותר קאבל החמוץ שלי.
והם בידיים.
סיימנו בדיוק
איזה עמוד הם מתכוונים
והיהודים השוער הוא אני הייתי הקפטן של הקבוצה
אלי או רוחות
לפיה הוא
אליהו שם לך את זה
בבטנו המזרחי. זה היינו מראים בדיוק
מה הוא שאליה חוסם להם.
לעומת זאת, כשהיו תחרויות
עם החוץ,
אז
הערבים נתנו לנו תגבורת. את השוער
קראו לשוער גולג'י,
האיש של ארי גולד.
ואנחנו כשהייתה להם התחרות, נתנו להם את הקשה למרכזי. שימו שתי
כבר כלפי חוץ היינו מאוחדים כלפי בן.
יש הרבה זכרונות מהימים ההם
וירה
שם. אמרתי ערבית פלסטינאית.
הייתי יושב בבתי קפה
כי מסתובב איתם.
הייתי כנה
כש
התבגרתי, היה לי שפם.
הייתי אוהב ללכת בימי שישי למסגד אל אקסה,
לשמוע את הדרשה.
איש לא יכול היה להעלות על דעתו שאני יהודי
בימין, לבית הספר למודיעין. אני לימדתי את המרגלים שלנו,
יודעת מוסלמית,
ויהיה
חיינו, כך
באני
בדירה קטנה עצמו
ובירושלים
לא הצלחת למצוא עבודה?
איפה למדת לפני שהיא
הייתה בבית ספר בירושלים. למה
לא בירושלים הגעתי לכיתה הולך, אני חושב, הולך לדבר
על זה שנה למדת בבית הספר בבית הספר ואמרתי אותו ב שלושים וארבע. הלכתי לשים מנהל המזרחי.
איזה בית ספר. זה היה הראשון של סיימת,
אמרתי לבית המדרש לזמן מה, למדו שם בבית הספר.
זה היה בית ספר עממי רגיל
עם דגש
אל יחדור
אל טולו על תלמוד.
שיננתי לי פרקים שלמים ותנ ך
שאני עד היום יכול. הלכנו להם בעל פה,
אבל
הוא היה יותר קיצוני מבחינה דתית
בחג הנטיעות ביתו משמעת. כשכל בתי הספר הלכו לתא.
לנו אסור היה לצאת מהחצר.
מדובר
כי אנחנו לא שותפים לציונים.
כן,
הייתי שם תלמיד מצטיין.
תעודת הסיום כתבו לי אפילו מרגלית הכיתה.
הגעתי לשיא מנהל המזרחי.
אחרי שסיימת
אחרי ששילמתי, זרק אותי
בבית הספר מהוריו. גם בנות למדו תכנס
להלם
וכולם הלכו עם כובעים
ויהיה
התפללנו תפילת מנחה בתחילת שחרית.
בנו לא בנוי, בוודאי שלא
על ידינו. היה בית ספר למלך
לירושלים
שישנם היה חרוט על בבית הספר
להציל לבית לאמת.
אנחנו היינו
מתבססים על הגדרות ורואים בנות מתעמלות
ומכנסיים קצרים.
תפקידן של המורים היה כמוך, לגרש אותנו
בסמינר המזרחי
ואחר כך עברת ל סי מנהר המזרח
בירושה. עומד לדרוש למורים
שם
הייתה
עליונות. אשכנזי
התרבות שלנו
ואני באתי מבית
אותי.
הייתי מבאי ביתו של הדרדסים. לימים הרב הראשי,
הוא היה מעודד אותי להתווכח איתו בדרשה שלו בשבת
אני הרבה למדתי ממנו,
לא יכולתי לקבל את
זה.
היה לנו בית כנסת,
זה בבית הספר שיתפללו בליל שבת. באחד,
בכל פעם אחת התלמידים
היה החזק.
כשאני הייתי החזן קראתי בנוסח יהודי בבל.
אז יותר לא נתנו לי
טוב, אז עשיתי שם איזה סידור שלו. כל פעם של שעון החשמל
נדלק בליל שבת היה
קצר
אז במשך כמה חודשים לא התפללו
כי היה חופש.
הגשת אותם.
איך
נשטה אותם? לא התקיימו, ממתין
מנהל בית הספר,
הרב
אלעזר מאיר ליפשיץ.
לדעתי הוא היה הגון. אני למדתי ממנו
לדבר עברית לסגנן בעברית. הוא היה לדעתי אחד השחיינים הטובים ביותר.
בעמל רב רכשתי אחר כך את הספרים שהוא כתב,
אבל כשאבא האורח תורם,
היו הרבה גורמים.
נכנס לכיתה,
היה אומר לאורח אדון דוקטור, יש לנו
קיבוץ ולא
יהיה. פרנסין,
קומו
שוב
בוחרים,
קומו,
תשבו
חלה במקומו
כשהוא
בבגדד עם
קומו
אני לא קול.
זה מסתכל עליי ואומר לי בגדד. אם אמרתי
אני מבס,
מה זה אותו דבר. קום
בסיכום
אחרי ארבע שנים בסמינר
הוראה של מבית הספר,
בתעודה היה כתוב נטול כושר אינטלקטואלי, ויש לך מכור לעבודה
כפיים
וכשהלכתי לא
מורה לפסיכולוגיה.
לימים,
פרופסור אין נאכלו. אוניברסיטת בר אילן,
כלומר הייתי ו
אתה
נולדת
עם ידיים של זהב
בראש של עופרת
לך וסיפור נס בידיך.
אני האמנתי לו,
ולהיפך.
היה לי כיף אשראי מטומטם. אני
אני כבר לא חייב להורים שלי כלום,
כי להורים שלי
הרבה ציפיות כשיגדל.
תודה.
רציתי לי והוא הציע לי להתייעץ למשטרה, לומר לי אתה בהריון, אתה הולך יפה מקום.
איזה משטרה
הרבי שלו, הפלשתינאית
זה.
אבל אז זה ירד
תחום של מינימום
חמישה רגל. עשרה אינץ'
בעצם
לייחס לו חמישה סנטימטרים.
שמתי חמישה סנטימטרים, קפון בכאב,
שמתי חמש לירות שוחד לשר. זה
לא. אז אני לא התקבל
יישוב העובדים בירושלים.
זה
הייתי משוררת בביתו של קצין בכיר אנגלי.
כשהייתי הלא מנהלת משק בית על בקה אנגליה זקנה
והיה לו פועל ערבי ש
עשה את הספונג'ה בכתה ואת העצים
למלא את האורח לקראת החורף, ואני הייתי בארץ הביניים
וכעבור שבוע גיליתי שהיה קצין
הומו שקשורה.
ברחתי שלי, שם
הייתי עוזר לו, מזכיר בלשכתו של הרב עוזיאל הרב בלושי,
אז פורנזי
ו.
חיפשתי עבודה ומצאתי עבודה בתל אביב, בבית משחק וחלקי חילוף
יכול להיות
תוך זמן קצר הייתי ממונה
אל השוק הערבית.
כן,
יפו,
חיפה,
נצרת.
על איזה שנה אנחנו
הגענו לשנה? אנחנו מדברים על לא מאוד
ארבעים.
היו גם הרבה הברכות של חלקי חילוף לסוריה שהייתה בשלטון הגרמנים,
הכיבוש הגרמני.
וכך באתי עם חוגה איימי בקשרים עם חוקי המשחק.
משם הובלתי לבונה שומרים.
תספר לי מה זה היה?
איך
מאיזה יקום השומרים קסאמים מול היישובים
הם
היו
משבועות.
היו פרדסים לא היו.
זה יהיה
בעונות הקיץ.
מבטיחים
קרמיים.
וזה ארגון של היהודים ששמו שם. היו שם שני ארגונים מקבילים,
אחד של
חקלאים
בני המושבות
ואחד שלא הסתדרו.
אז אני הייתי בזה של
המושבות
ויראה
שם הסתובבתי, הכרתי את הפלאחים
הבדואים.
אני יהיה
לתקופת נערותי כשעוד הייתי בבית הספר היסודי.
אז הרב ניסים זאב עם העובר האנושי
אומר לאביך, אבל שהילד
לבזבז זמן או בפוטבול
כשאלך וייצור מים על ידיו של
חכם
היה מזרחן יהודי זקן
יצחק בימין. יהודה, אחיו של פרופסור אברהם שלום, עבודה
היהודי הראשון שהוזמן
לארצו באוניברסיטת מדריד אחרי ייעוץ.
אבל
הוא יהיה עיוור.
הוא התאבד
ותפקידי היה
לקרוא
ספרים
לכתוב לו,
ושם היכרתי
ספרות נוער
ואת הדת המוסלמית.
אני חושב שזה נותן לי יותר משהו אוניברסיטה. עשיתי את זה שנתיים.
הלכתי אליו פעמיים בשבוע. חרוץ אחריו.
למה ארגון השוורים?
באתי בקשר עם הבדואים
הולכים, והתפקיד היה
לשמור על
הפונה אנשים אל הכרמים.
מגיע לך את זה. תלי נשק
איך
רואה אותנו ויצא
רגע על זה כדי לחדש את הרישיון. כל שנה היה צריך לתת שוחד לפקיד.
אבל זה הלך
כך גם קיבלת רישיון נהיגה כשהייתי יצא
רוביו
כשנבחרת להיות גם מזכיר ארגון וחברה,
אומר
השומרים
כן, הלכתי כמה פעמים לפס ולא הצלחת.
ובעל איזה מוח
ממה לאליהו השתגעה?
אני עובר פה כסף.
אנחנו עשינו ניסיון בגינו נהג
כשכבר נוהג עשרים שנה באוטובוס. וגם הוא לא עברת את הטסט?
אתה רוצה רישיון?
אני בא אליך מחר
תסבירי
תעודת זיהוי
שתי תמונות בחמש לירות,
ובאותו שבוע כבר היה לי רישיון נהיגה.
זה
היה סדר של
פליק
טוב בכך
הגעתי
למלחמת השחרור.
לפני שנגיע ל מלחמת השחרור ברשותך, אני אשאל אותך שאלה.
התקופה היא תקופת מלחמה
באירופה?
כן.
השאלה הראשונה שלי
היא
האם אתה זוכר את התקופה של החשש שגרמ
שעכשיו שהגרמנים ידעו בוודאי
בזמנו את
זה
היה להם. למשל
הם הסתובבו וחלקו ביניהם את הבתים
כן.
הם חילקו ביניהם את אנשים. למי הכוונה?
לא יהיה יופיו
יתמנה. אפילו היה להם אפילו מועמד
להיות מושל מחוז לוד שכלל גם על תל אביב,
כאשר
כאשר הגרמנים יבואו
שמו היה אמין אנדרוס
וקראו לו אמין פון הלן ראוס!
מה אתם מסכים? יהודים מה
עשיתי?
מה? מה? מה הרגשתי מה עשיתי
כיהודים?
שום תבונה, רק כמו ממקומות.
אנחנו
בבית המשרד לחלקי חילוף למכוניות עשה הרבה כסף.
למשל,
הערבים העדיפו לקנות רק תוצרת גרמניה
ו
כשאני הייתי מראה לו מבריקים אז זה אומר
אני רוצה מבריגים מי ג'ין אמרה לי?
מה
אמרו על איזה גיבור כן, תוצרת גרמניה.
אז ברור שאנחנו על כך. מקופסאות
מבריגים את עושה לגרמניה
בילינו אותם מבריגים אחרים מכרנו אותם במחיר כפול.
כן, מר אותי,
השאלה השנייה
אתה,
אני,
לפני שנגיע ל מלחמת השחרור
בתקופת המלחמה,
היישוב היהודי כאן.
תירגע, חי בתל אביב אתה שייך לארגון השומרים.
שמאי אדם, מה קורה ליהדות אירופה?
זה
רק לקראת הסוף, ילד
לפני זה
לא יאומן!
היא היה גיוס לצבא הבריטי.
אוי ויי,
ברוריה,
נמשיך,
היא
מענה אותי. סיפרת לנו ש מעט מאוד היה ידוע בתקופת המלחמה, רק לקראת הסוף.
מה הוא? מה גורלה של יהדות אירופה?
כאילו לא ידעת רק לקראת הסוף,
כי
לפני שנגיע ל מלחמת השחרור
תוכל לספר לי
אם וכאשר היתה במחתרות
החיים בארץ
זה
אני הייתי מקורב לעצם,
כי
לכי לומר, ההגנה לא הגיע לשכונות המרוחקות.
גם יצחק נבון היה חבר. בעיקר
אני חי עכשיו.
איפה אתה חי עכשיו? בתקופת אני מדבר שם
באיזה מקום מושלם
המשפחתי בירושלים. אני בתל אביב,
אני הייתי
מפקד בנעל בית מחוז תל אביב בין על זדונית
מעור איברי לאומי
שזו הייתה עזרו. האינטלקטואלית של העצם,
וכשהיא הסתיימה המלחמה
היה יהודי בשם בנימין מוצקי.
כשהיה נציב בית אל בפולין, מזכירו של ז'בוטינסקי,
הוא הקים סביבו
תנועה
נוראה תואם.
כשעוזבים את זה ימין ונכנסים לארגון
כי אנחנו האמנו
שמה שאנחנו צריכים עכשיו לעשות אחרי השואה זה להקים מדינה
ומי שהקים את המדינה שידבר
בן גוריון
ולכן אנחנו לא חשבתם
שמי שהקים את המדינה זה דויד בן גוריון
וזו העדיפות הראשונה.
ואז עזבנו את מחנה הימים.
דוקטור לובוצקי היה
לימים דוקטור בנימין אליאב, הוא היה אורך הבור של מופרעים
ויהיה
הצטרפנו לו הגנה.
מתי זה היה? לפני שנה
מאוד פעיל,
לא
נכנסתי להסתברות.
באחד במאי היינו זורקים אבנים
וצועקים רגל אדון הוריד לתיאום,
אז פתאום נהייתי חלק מההסתדרות
ושברתי רגל. אדון ניסה למרום
כן,
ציון
ואני
בחבורה הזאת היה
משהו
נגע ללבו וצלמים שר האוצר
במדינת ישראל ועוד הרבה אנשים
שהגיעו למסקנה
כשהם נוטשים
את הימים
הם עוברים למחנה ההסתדרותי. אני הייתי אחד,
וזה בעקבות החשיבה של בן גוריון.
הוא זה שאנחנו צריכים מדינה עכשיו, ורק בן גוריון נכון להקימו
שחייבים לחזק את ידיו
ותוכל לספר לי
על הפעילות שלכם בהגנה.
היא אה
אנחנו שהצטרפנו להגנה,
היינו בכל זאת
תודה.
לא יהודים כשרים.
לא הייתה קצת הסתייגות
מחיפה,
מכיוון
ופה ושם נעזרו
בי
הקשרים שלי עם הערבים ביפו,
אבל לא היתה לפעילות מיוחדת.
כן,
ואז היהודים החליטו
להקים עיר אווריס על יד באר שבע. איש לא אמי שבאר שבע תהיה מילולית בו
והיה לזה
שם
אפיקים בנגב
ואני
נועדתי להיות המוכתב של העיר
הזאת
כדי אז התחלתי להסתובב בנגב.
הכרתי בדואים בצפון
ואלה
שרואים את זה
זה לא הייתה רעה.
זה לא היתה בעיה.
כך התחילו הקשרים שלי עם הנגב
נועדתי להיות המוכתב
של העיר.
טוב, אחרי
שנה הייתי
חושב העיר של באר שבע יהודי טונה
ואז
הסוכנות הקימה בית ספר מוכתרים של הנגב
ואני הייתי שמדריך חלושי
גם זה
כבר החלטה כיום
תספר לי היום אז אתה מדבר על כ ט בנובמבר
אני מדבר. אל תספר לי מה עובר עליך.
בשמחה
יש מדינות
יצאנו לרחוב לרקוד
אחד מאוד אור הבוקר
ועל מחלת במוקד התחילו הרציחות.
רציחות
כן,
זה יהיה
זה לא סכום כמה יהודים בכבישים הכבישים נחסמו.
מי רצח?
איך?
מה הוא מבין?
זה היה שלטון המנדט
זה היה עדיין שלטון המנגרובים. מי יעזרו?
איך הגינו על היהודים?
כמעט שלא
אנחנו גם לא היינו זקוקים להגנה. הסכנה הייתה
במעבר ממקום למקום.
למשל, דרך אבו כביר כבר אי אפשר היה לעבור
אם מסגד
לא מה שהם המסגרת והבול. תל אביב יפו
חזן דלק
ירו אז
ברחוב הירקון בין רחוב והוא לא,
לא
אל רחוב הרב קוק הימית, לא שם.
סקט אבן
עסק יחול כדי שאפשר יהיה לעבור
במסגרת באבו כביר ירו לעבר רחוב הרצל, אז גם שם שמו
ויהיה סקיי חו ל כדי להגן על המעבר.
כן,
זה יהיה אז כבר היו לי קשורים
אם המחלקה
הערבית
של הסוכנות.
בראש המחלקה עמד אליעד ששון לייל עם השר אליהו פלאפון
ומנהל המחלקה יעקב שמולי,
לדעתי, והוא היה אחד הגדולים שהבינו בנושאים רבים הספרים שלו.
כשהוא כתב עד היום
הם משמשים לי
רקע היסטורי,
אם כי במסקנות לא היינו תמיד שלמים.
ואז העלית ייעצר
כשאני אתחיל לדבר על הערבים ברדיו.
תודה.
אז כל התחנות הערביות
שידור בערבית ספרותית.
תשעים אחוז
לערבים בארץ. אז לא יעלו קרואו?
אני זוכר שהייתי יושב בבית קפה במעורבות
בשכונה שגרנו
ברוממה,
והרדיו היום
מדבר בערבית ספרותית.
הם לא הבינו. הם שאלו אותי מאמר הרדיו.
כן, לזה בכלל את הלב. בית קפה נהדר.
למדתי שם הרבה דברים.
כשה רגיעה נותן חדשות רעות,
אז הם זורקים עליו נעליים,
וכשהיה קורקורן
היו מתנשקים אותו ואני לוקח את המכשיר עצמו רגל
ומבקשים ממנו אצלך.
כן,
בבית,
לשימוש המזוהם של בית הקפה, מישהו צייר בית ראש על הקיר,
את המופתי של ירושלים חאג' אמין.
האם המצנן פת והמשקפיים עומד עירום ועושה מעשה סדום ב ויצמן
שימו עומד עירום,
וכדי להסיר ספק אם על גופו של ויצמן
תעלו מגן
ציו מגן דויד וכתבו וויזמן
כן,
אני העליתי הצעה בפני
היה קושי מולי
כשאני
הבטח
פרשנות
על דיוק
בערבית. מדובר
מתוך כוונה, מתוך כוונה שכל השומעים הפלשתיני הם יבינו מה שאני מדבר.
מה רצית להגיד להם?
את כל המסר שהיה לישוב היהודי להגיד
היא קודם כל פרשנות פוליטית.
לא להילחם.
לא כדאי להם להילחם. אנחנו אנשי שלום.
התעכבתי את המתנדבים שבאו
לעזור להם מכל הארצות,
אבל לא נקראתי בשמי תהיה. האנגלים היו בארץ.
אילו הייתי אומרת שמי היו אוסרים אותי,
אז בחרתי להתקינו ידעו בין לא פה.
דיוויד אל שאומר
אני חושב שזה היה
מפעל.
אין הנחתום מעיד על עיסתו, אבל זה לא חשוב הרבה יותר
מוניטין.
ועד היום,
אחרי מלחמת השחרור,
הלכתי לשמעון אם אמרתי לאחור
יש מדינה, אני חוזר לשמי האמיתית.
אז המנהל אליהו,
רכשת לך כל כך הרבה מאוד
כן,
כשאתה עד יום מותך, תישאר קרוב, אינו טוב. גם אחרי יום אותך
דיוויד השומר
כן,
וכנראה שהוא סבא דראק,
אני אעזור לך,
בסדר? כי את אומרת כיף שלכם.
אני,
אני אני ברירה,
בסדר?
ואולי גם היום
אני עדיין משתמש בכינוי
בעודנו הפוך
לך.
אנחנו נחזור לי
התחילה.
אנחנו היינו ב כ ט בנובמבר. סיפרת לנו
על השמחה מאוד יהודים ברחובות.
ואז התחלתי
את השידורים בעוד יום.
הערבים חשבו אותי למה שאתה
סחיר חבר של היהודים.
אני זוכר שהוא חברי
רצח
סאדאת.
הייתי ראש העיר
ויצא משלחת
הוזמנה משלחת של ראשי העולים על ידי ממשלת
מצרים.
תודה.
היו שם ראשי ערים יותר גדולות או
איך אומרים שום כבודי?
קבעו אותי ליושב ראש המצליח המשלחת.
אתה היית אז
ראש עיריית באר שבע.
כן.
די.
אנחנו נכנסים לקבלת פנים במשרד ראש הממשלה. שולחן ערוך. אנחנו יושבים
ואני קם ואומר כמה
מילות נימוס בערבית.
אז ראש הממשלה, באמת תסלח לי.
אתה לא זה שדיברת ברדיו ב?
אמרתי לו, נכון?
לא, לא. איך זה שאתה עדיין חי?
נכון שלא, אדוני. אתה רוצה להרוג אותי?
אז זה אומר לא.
אבל אם ב
היית בן,
איך זה שאתה עדיין חי?
אני אמרתי שם פנים של זקן
כי אז הקרקעות היו בידי הזקנים,
הרכוש, הכסף.
אם האב נתן לבנו חל ק הוא בנה לבית אימו לא נתנו, אז הוא הסתובב.
אם הוא נותן לו מורה, אז הוא קנה אישה. אם הוא לא נתן לנו מואר, הוא הסתובב ברוב קוטו
צריך,
אז אני הייתי על זה. כן,
ברשותם.
תודה.
בסוף.
או למשל,
עוד לא היו לי ילדים,
אבל באחת התוכניות סיפרתי איך שלקחתי את הנכד שלי לגמרי היו
זקן.
השתמשתי אפילו במילים טורקיות פה ושם. כזקנים ופלסטין
דיברו טורקית.
השידור האלה נמשכו עד שהתמניתי לשופט,
ואז נשיא בית המשפט העליון,
הסלעים,
כי זה
נורא מעורבות פוליטית.
ואז היא התחילה
המלחמה מלחמת
כנופיות,
עוד לפני הכנסתה המדינה.
תספר לי בתחילת
יקירי, אני הייתי בתל אביב,
ירו על תל אביב בכל העברה
והיו עמודות
בגבולות תל אביב,
ואז
על פרצופו.
כשאני אסתובב ומישהו ילין
ואני אקרא קריאות
לא ערבים,
אולי קצת לשכנע אותם, אולי קצת לרפות את ידיהם,
אולי קצת כדי להראות איפה הם מחזיקים
את כלי הנשק.
לימים, כשזה מאוד הצליח,
אז הוחלט
להפוך את זה לתקליטים
ולשדר את זה. מה העמדות היהודיות
לערבים
לא נשתמרו בידיי.
אבל כש שימשה סאסון
לשעבר שכבר איננו באיטליה,
מזרחה ומובהק
הלך לעולמו.
יעקב נמרודי מצא בתוך העיזבון שלו
כמה תקליטים. ואז
אני אשמיע לך אחד
בדרך.
אלה הם דבריך,
לא
לערבים, לא ערבית
ב
מרוב מכל דבר פרות.
את מה הוא
השמן בחובו?
אין טוב. בניין העירייה על ערוץ
רועש שם. טוב, טוב רפואות קובן נוער
הופקעה, אבל באופן אל
אשר מיד.
מי את? אמצעי קצת לנוער קוף.
אין צורך תצפתתי דואה שמנה. עוד אלכוהול,
נכון?
הוא אינו לא ידעו,
נהנים מהתמונה יש שבת
להאמין אבל אורוגוואי
הוא לא אפילו לא רק ישרוד אומר
הוא קונור
לעיונה
אולי גם רפורמים קור
הוא אינו עדין יותך קורא לכל
להיות
בנקאי תפילתם קבורתה צפרות
מהגנת
אומות כפועל
אפרד יישב
גופו קונקובר ערקו
אם זה היה כל כך הנחשב לו
יד אחריו בפקק טלמון
אותם או פה
הם דעות.
תודה
איך
הוא? חוק פנימית
תודה רבה. אלא היום אלה היו דבריך?
כן זה כל חיה בערבית לערבים מושמע ברדיו
לו
זהו שמע בתקליטים, מהחפירות שלנו לחפירות,
לחפירות של הערבים לחפירות שלו תסביר לנו מה אתה אומר כאן.
כתבתי לך שם
משהו.
כן, ויהי היה שם תרגיל נבזי.
היו להם שירים
לאומניים
אחד מהם שהואשמה בכל התחנות הערביות
חאליסי הפיגור
אפילו לא חייבת לדבר
היא, אה
תנו לו חרב לדבר
יום המערכה אין רחמים
בני הדודים הם רבים
האש והחרב יתגלה לו אותם
תנו לו חרב לדבר
שאלו את זה בהתלהבות
הישיר המתנדבים
כשבאו מועצות או לא
באנו אלייך יפה לא ספין בנו ולהעיר
באנו אלייך
להרים את מושא איך
פרופיל
באנו אלייך יפה, אוסטין
באנו אליי
באנו אלייך להילחם והוא יוודא
בנו אליי.
ואני הייתי משדר את השיר זה היה לי את הכלי חובל של המצב היה שונה זה היה,
הממ ממש יצירה,
אז כן.
ג'ינה, לכי. אפור לוסין ג'ינה ליק,
באנו אלייך יפה לא סיימה
ג'ינה לכלל אישי לנהל ג ג'ינה ליק באנו אלייך להרים את המסע שלך. באנו אלייך
באנו אלייך להילחם באויבים שלך
וכאן הייתי מכניס קטע משלי.
ג'ינה עלה כי עפר נוסעים
היא
האלק
ג'ינה, לכלל נקיה לגדי מנהיג. באנו אלייך לזה אלף אנשים שלך באנו אלייך
ואז היא פותחים
באש מכל המעמדות.
וזה היה ממש כיף.
אל היועץ תקליטים.
אני ברשותך. איתרתי, אחר כך אחר כך
באיזה של הפגישות ולבצע
לפני כן ברשותך, אני רוצה בעברית להקריא שורה אחת ממה ששמענו בערבית. כן.
היי, אתם משאבא,
הבחורים של פלסטין. תקשיבו,
בשביל מי אתם נלחמים?
לוחמים
אתם ששומרים על האדמה בהעמדות
כשהשמש מכה בראש חיים ביום והכובע ציינה בלילה.
מי ירוויח מזה שאתם לוחמים
אתם?
לכם תהיה תועלת מהמלחמה הזאת.
גם הרבנים של המנהיגים
איפה הבנים שלהם
שוכבים? לידכם היא השבת.
עומדים מאחורי שקי החול ויורים.
לא,
יש, ג'מה!
הבנים שלהם יותר חכמים מכם.
וואלה,
הם יושבים וצוחקים עליך. אם
הם מקיפים.
עושים חיים בקו בריטים בבהירות,
במועדוני הלילה עם הנערות ורקדניות הבטן.
מספיק, בחורים,
סיימו את השיחה שלכם בראש.
תחזרו כל אחד לעניינים שלו.
חבל שתהרגו פה
סתם
תלכו לאיבוד.
תחזרו.
אלה. זה היה תרגום ממה ששמענו את זה דבר אחד, אבל
היו הרבה תקליטים כאלה, אבל אין לי את כולם.
תראה, אני יכול אני מצטער על השיר הזה.
לפני שאני הייתי רוצה
תספר לי גם היום הכרזה את המדינה.
איפה היית
יום החלטות המדינה. הייתי בבית
ברחוב יהודה הלוי. הגענו אצל העולים של ברוריה,
והיא זו תיאוריה.
הוא באמת
תספר לנו.
אני רואה את העתיד.
הדבר הטוב שהיה אליו עם נטלי. אנחנו נשואים
למעלה מ.
הנישואים שלהם היו
עצורים.
אז יצאנו והעמדנו,
לא רחוק
נ ',
היכל העצמאות,
וזה היה המוזיאון של דיזנגוף.
שמענו את זה ברמקולים.
מה שמעתם
את הכרזה המדינה
היינו במרחק מאה מטר ממך. את מבן גוריון,
כלומר בחוץ
והיא את.
אבל היה ברור שמי, אז אחרי זה הולכת מלחמה.
מה הייתה ההרגשה כשבן גוריון מקריא את ההכרזה
ומשק? כאן זה ההיסטוריה.
אני כאן.
לא היו ויכוחים. להכריז מדינה, לא להחליף מדינה.
האמריקאים אמרו שזה עוד מוקדם.
שרת אמר שלא צריך להרגיז את העולם או בבן גוריון התעקש
לספר לי על ההרגשה שלך. מה קורה לך באותו יום?
אני חושב שהיו
ימים של ניסים ונפלאות.
מצד אחד אסונות
הרוגים.
הרבה חברים טובים שלי נפלו
בקרבות האלה,
אבל מצד שני מסתמן עתיד לעם ישראל
שאנחנו חלק ממנו.
אתה אומר שידעתם
עם השמחה ש
כמו
תראי,
בהחלטה על החלוקה
היית שמחה גדולה?
לא יודע. אני
לא תיארתי לעצמי
מה יבוא בעקבותיה.
ויותר חשוב
חשבנו בכה קצת. הענבים יתנגדו, אבל הם קיבלו מדינה,
קיבלו שטח עצום.
אחרי מלחמת ששת הימים דיין, שהיה שר הביטחון,
ביקש ממני, כראש עיריית באר שבע
לקשור קשרים
עם ראש עיריית חברון ועם ראש עירייה ועזב.
כן,
ראש עיריית חברון, שח מוחמד עלי ג'עפרי,
איש חכם.
בוודאי שהוא לא היה אוהב ישראל, אבל לא יהיה איש חכם.
ובינינו, נקשרו קשרי ידידות, המשפחות, ביקורו אלט אליהם. אצלנו בבאר שבע,
ואנחנו בעיקר בעונת הכרמים, היינו אצלם
פירוש עיריות.
אז
אז ראש עד השורש,
הוא היה
מסויג.
כשרוח
לא הגעתי איתו לקרבה אישית.
ופעם אני יושב אצלו,
ואני אומר לא. תשמע, אתם הערבים
מומחים
לאבד הזדמנויות.
היתה לכם הזדמנות לעזוב.
הציעו לכם מדינה
שכללה
את באר שבע,
את אשקלון,
תוכנית החלוקה, את אשדוד,
את לוד,
את רמלה,
את כל הגליל המערבי.
נהריה, שהיתה עיר יהודית,
הייתה חלק מהמדינה הערבית.
נצרת
ירושלים הייתה מובלעת בינלאומית, אבל מסביבה הייתה המדינה הערבית,
ואתם ביטלתם את זה. איפה הייתם עומדים היום? היא לא הייתם מקבלים את החלוקה,
אז הוא אומר לי במחשבה שנייה,
גם היום הייתי דוחה את ההחלטה
חלוקות,
ונאמר לו מדוע
אמרתי לו לא.
אני יושב פעם בבית
בלב פונדס.
יש לי שלושים חדרים
כשהיא הרעשנים, רבותיי.
ואתה בה
פליט,
גירשו אותך. מי פולניה?
שחטו את המשפחה שלך
ואתה מבקש אצלי שני חברים. חדר
לא ייתן מנוחה
כי זה שלי.
לקחת בכוח,
לקחת בכוח
אני אזרוק אותך עוד עשר שנים הוד מהשנה
אז אמרתי לו אל תסלח ביחד אני רוצה להזכיר לך שאני לא בפולניה.
משפחתי הייתה בעיראק
עוד אלף שנים לפני הופעת הנביא מוחמד.
אתה מסתכל אליי בבוז ואומר לכולכם מי פולניה.
תודה.
נחזור ל
ל מלחמת השחרור
זה בשלב כלשהו. אני כבר לא זוכר מתי
גיסו אותי לצער.
המספר הצבאי שלי היה
אני, בן עשרים אלף המגויסים הראשונים,
אחד שבע שיש להם שאלות
כן,
אחרי כיבוש ירפו
נשלחתי להקים שהמשטרה ערבית.
זאת אומרת, היה איתי אליהו גורדון.
זה
היה בית ספר ללחימה. הוא הכניס כמה סוסים
והוא היה
ממונה עליי,
אבל אחרי שבועיים הוא נפצע
וזה נשאר.
הקמתי שהמשטרה
איך זה הכתיבה
עוד
שהעברתי אותו למשטרת ישראל.
השר
בכור שלום שטרית
היה שר המיעוטים והמשטרה.
אחר כך אוריד את הנאותים. נשארה המשטרה. אבל אז הוא היה גם שר המיעוטים
והתקבלה החלטה בממשלה
להוציא עיתון ערבי יומי
לערבים שנשארו בישראל
במשימה.
לא עליי.
כן
היה לו שם. לעיתון יצא
יום
היום
אל יום.
זה
לא היתה משימה קלה,
טוב לאחרים, משרדים. כל הבתים ויפו היו נטושים.
תפוס
אין כוס.
אז לקחתי לי
יהודי, מוחלת, כפוף
ועברנו יחד
בכל בתי הדפוס.
הערבים
הספרותיות
קיבלו אותי. אותי אפשר להדפיס.
אחר כך נסעתי לנצרת
והיה שם אבי שאוב, חאקים,
וביקשתי ממנו פה על לדפוס,
ואז
אנחנו איתנו. כמה פולי דפוס
זה עלה? קצת כסף. שום דבר לא הולך בחינם,
כנראה שגם היום,
ויהיה
פתחנו דפוס חדש בערבית, מה שלא היה.
היה שם יהודי שהבין היטב בדפוס ברבי היה מדפיס והבין ערבית. שמו היה כל זה
ויהיה
המערכת
היה
מיכאל אסף
טוב, יש שם ושני מזרחנים ותיקים שעבדו בדבר
ויעבדו בעיתון הערבי של ההסתדרות. חקיקת ', אמר,
ארגן מורשת של הפצה
בכל הארץ,
אבל
אחרי שהשלמתי את תפקידי בעיתון התחיל לפעול.
מה אמא? היו הכתבות בעיתון? מה כתבתם?
אני לא כותב.
מה כתבו אחרת?
קודם כל, קודם כל חדשות
חדשות
מהארץ.
חדשות מהעולם,
חדשות מהמלחמה
זה
חדשות מעולם הפליטים,
והעיתון כמובן ל
למי ערבייה
ישראל.
כלומר
מאוד לא היו אז ערבי. הישראלים היו
הערבים שנשארו בישראל.
כן,
זה יהיה.
השלמתי את זה. העיתון
לא
הועברתי ליחידה ורוזיטה
היחידה הדרוזית, אפילו הדרוזים,
כשהייתי לראשונה
כן,
ובזה תם חלקית. בכלל,
השאלה
מה עשתה היחידה הדרוזים במלחמה
הוא
הסיפור.
קודם כל,
היו לנו
כפרים
דרוזים
דלית אל כרמל ואעשה פיה,
ואלה היו מקורבים אלינו, למשל, שהאנגלים חיפשו את הבחור שהוא הסתתר בהישג יד
במארס. אפי הראייה
הייתה פלוגת
קומנדו
דרוזית
שנקרא השר היקרה,
והם התאמנו במחנה ישראל
בכניסה ללוד, מול המקום שהיום התעשייה האווירית,
ולחמו לצידנו
למן ההתחלה
במקביל,
כי יש בידוד
דרוזי
בהר הדרוזים
לסוריה,
בפיקודו של
ש. קיווה
שהיה קצין בצבא הבריטי,
והם נלחמו. מובן.
היו קרבות עקובים מדם.
הקרב הקשה ביותר היה כבר לעומת יוחנן.
זהו זה.
הסתערו שבע פעמים
על העמדות שלנו,
והם התקרבו
עם סכינים,
עם עורקים בפה.
אלוף משה כרמל מתאר את הקרב הזה כאחד הקרבות המרים בצה ל,
אבל האם במקום הדרוזים שעזרו לנו
היה
שהחל אדיב אמור אוקון
שיח' סאלח נפץ בספרון.
לימים
היו חברי כנסת
והם ניהלו
קשר.
אם
הדרוזים שבאו מארב,
הם יסבירו להן
שהיהודים לא נשים, נשים דרוזיות,
והיהודים מקבלים את הדרוזים
אל
בזמן שהם לחמו הדרוזים נגדנו.
החברים שלהם שדדו את המקדש של הדרוזים.
נא להישאר
לידה
חיטים.
והנה
הם אפילו לציבור,
וצריך לבנות אותם.
הם היו לו חומר
מצוינים.
ואם
אני נשלחתי ליחידה,
בכלל סיימתי את מלחמת השר?
בואי נאמר
בשורה ונציה לעבוד על בעית נוצות
בשנה.
איך?
באיזה שנה? שוב פעם
לא גמרתי קורס קצינים.
לא גמרתי כל סמן קראפין.
לא עברתי אימון הופרט.
אימוני הירי בזריקת הלימונים שלי היו
ארגון השומרים עוד לפני הקמת המדינה,
אבל עסקתי בתחום
הלא כמו הפסיכולוג.
ראיתי סגן מפקד יחידה
היחידה למלחמה פסיכולוגית. בצער
זה הייתי מדריך בבית הספר
המספר הרביעי,
אבל לא היו המסתערבים של היום
שהם מתאפרים, צובעים את הפנים, עורכים יום יומיים,
חוזרים הביתה. מתרחצים עושים מקלחת.
אנשים ישבו חודשים,
שנים
ואל צופנות
ושלחנו אותם יחד עם הפליטים הערבים.
כן,
כרבי במיתר. הוא שם
עשויה בדומה זק
ובלבנון
פחות באיבה.
איך הם יצרו קשר עם הארץ?
המכות.
הם עברו קורסים לקשר. הם עברו כולכם ל
פריצת מנעולים. אין
חדירה לבניין דרך הגג.
אני בטוח שהיום עושים. זה יצא בסוף.
ואתה היית.
ואני הייתי אחד המדריכים.
היה לך גם
הייתה בין אלה גם שנעשו או שנשארת על שום
לשר. אולי
לא רק לנסוע
להיכנס לארץ ערבית,
וגם לא להיכנס לילד שיש לה קשר
מדינות גדולות,
כי על עיקול
רדיופוני כזה.
אחרי שאמרתי משפט אחד, זהות
הקורבן,
סיפרתי לך מה יהיה ראש ממשלת מצרים?
אז אילו הייתי יוצא
למדינה
צריך להזין בארבע שעות העיתונים אותי.
כן,
אבל זה
איך
סליחה.
כשפתחו את הקו לרומניה,
נתנו לי ולאשתי
כרטיס כבוד של
נסיעה בטיסה הראשונה.
כן,
כדי
גם אם אחרי זה אני מקבל טלפון,
אליהו, יש
קורס בסל נותן, ואתה צריך לתת כמה הרצאות על לוחמה פסיכולוגית.
כלומר, מתי זה
לא, לא. אני ברומניה.
אז נדמה לך שאתה טיפש?
אין קורס, אין לוחמה פסיכולוגית והן רומניה.
והיא לא נעשה את זה
אחר כך.
במרכז השלטון המקומי. הייתי בביקור בברלין
המערבית,
ראש עיריית
עלינו מערבית. התיידדנו
מאוד
מאז
הוא אחר כך היה מנהל את תחנת הרדיו
כל אירופה.
הוא היה ממש ידידי ישראל.
אז הוא קורא לי ואומר
יש לי הזדמנות
שאתה תיסע
מחר
לגרמניה המזרחית.
הם לעתים רחוקות מאוד
מרשים,
ואתה אף פעם לא יודע מתי הם מרשים.
אני חושב שבשבילך
לביקור נורא מעניין
גם כראש עיר. גם
כאיש שמכיר את ההתפתחות של החברה האנושית.
תראה איך שני הימים
שהיו פעם עם אחד
אחרי כך וכך שנים
הפכו שונים מן הקצה אל הקצה.
למעשה, אני לא חושב שיש. היה אסור היה לי לנסוע,
אז הוא אומר לי זו הזדמנות. והשר לביטחון שלך? באמת אין לך שאלה?
הרגתי לא, ידידי.
אני בחיים אוקס ו
מה שאני חייב
ומה שאני עוכב.
הנסיעה לברלין המזרחית לא נופלת בקטגוריה
אלה.
לא, לא אני.
שלום.
הייתי מוגבל מאוד במשך הרבה שנים.
בגלל הכל.
אתה משתחרר מצה ל.
מתי אתה מתמנה לראש עיריית בראשית?
אני
אחרי משהו מצער.
הייתי עורך דין.
פוטרתי משרות
בתל אביב. בסניף,
בדרך
שלו.
עשיתי הרבה כסף.
אבל הלקוחות שלי היו עלונים.
והיו מקרים שזיק איתי
או
הוצאתי בעונש קל
לאנגלים.
ו
וזה מאוד באי כולו
היה משפט
מרגל. נשלח מקצוע
בו עם ילד.
והנה
הצלחתי
לשחרר אותם. משמעותו גווידו.
הוא נידון רק על כניסה בלתי חוקית. אבל
שם המונסון
ואז אריה ניר,
נציב בתי הסוהר מאוד
כשהיה ידידי. ויחד הבנק במודיעין.
אבל
מה
אתה זומם?
איך אתה מגן על האיש הזה?
אני חושב שהאיש הזה לא ייצא
מהכלא הישראלי.
ואז
הצגתי את מועמדותי
שהתמניתי לשופט.
הייתי השופט הראשון בנגב.
בית משפט השלום
בבאר שבע באשקלון
ובאילת.
וב
פיתו אותי, לחצו עליי. התמודדתי בבחירות
לעיריות.
נבחרתי חמש קדנציות
בפרצופו.
תודה.
ו באמצע הקדנציה
החמישית
הרגשתי שהשלמתי את התפקידים.
תודה.
הפטרון של באר שבע,
פנחס ספיר,
מת.
אני יודע שאני עצמי
מיותר.
ואז
התפתו
באמצע הקדנציה והקמתי את רשות השיפוט בהסתדרות.
מערכת משפטי שיפקח על כל
יהודי מגדולתה.
אז הסדר
בבנק הפועלים ו בקופת חולים
בביקור
וסולל בונה.
אז זהו זה.
ברשותך נעשה הפסקה.
הממשלתי
כלומר ניבוי
אמרת לנו אנחנו עכשיו שתינו קפה בהפסקה.
אמרת לי איזה משפט מאוד יפה הבדואי אומר בקשר לשתיית קפה או
אל כוחו אל מוחך. מושלם. הנותן
הקפה
נועד את צלילות הדעת,
לא למילוי הבטן,
ולכן הם שותים
קפה. מר
וטיפול בודדות
יפה.
אנחנו נחזור לעניינים
כי הייתי רוצה ברשותך, לחזור אחורה ו שתספר לנו על פרשת עלתה לי
כן,
אני
כמו כל יהודי
עכב בדרכו.
אחרי כל מה שיעזור
לנו.
הרקע שלי היה כי איש ימין,
כשעלתה לנה
הגיע
לחוף תל אביב.
אני הייתי בסיור
כמפקד משטרת יפו,
רכב טי על סוס.
מה עמדתי על גבעה
של ליד
החוף.
ראיתי את ההוא, נייר
התובע,
ראיתי את ראשם
עולה ממנו
וממש בכיתי.
אבל ימין
נוכחתי ש,
על אף במחיר גבוה עבור
בן גוריון, צדק
הוא בכך.
הוא מנה שאנחנו נהיה מדינה של מיליציות
ושל פלמנגו,
שכל אחת היא הצבאית.
הוא בא,
פרק את העץ אל בית הלחי. אבל הוא גם לא חס על הכל מכ
כדי שיהיה לנו
סבא היחיד
שעומד לפקודתה של ראש
של ממשלת ישראל לא חוקית.
אבל זה לקח לי הרבה שנים.
פיו
טוב,
עוד איזה שהוא נדבק בהיסטוריה שלנו.
עם השנים הראשונות,
מה שאנחנו
קוראים קראו לו אחר כך פרשת לבון, או עסק הביש במצרים.
תוכל להוסיף לנו פרטים?
אני הייתי
ביחידות
כש
הצבאית,
כשהספר בדברים האלה.
אבל פרשת לבון
הראה
כשאני כבר לא הייתי בצוות.
מי שחשף את הפרשה
זה
יוסי הראל.
בימים יוסי ההמבורגר
ש
בעבר,
כשהיה מפקד הפלוגה הניידת
בחללית,
הוא חסר את אותו דבר.
כן,
דיברתי על זה גם עם בן גוריון כשהייתי מכל רבה
ולא קיבלתי על דעתו
זו הייתה נבלעת
שהכפילה את הכישלון
הלפרקון שלומות.
זו היתה קנוניה
בין בנימין גיבלי, מפקד המודיעין,
לבין משהו ידי ים.
כשהכניסו אותו לפח,
מזכירה
אודטה אחר כך
שהיא זהיפה מכתב,
ואמרו אז שיהיה
משה דיין, הרמטכ ל כדי להכשיל את לבון.
הוא היה מעביר עשרות מסמכים
להחלטת השר.
והיו על שולחנו של לבון ערימות של דברים
שחייב לקרוא אותם שם. רמטכ ל עבר עליו
שזהו, שאותי לא מעט מאוד זמן.
בן גוריון לא אסלח ללבון.
הוא היה מוכן לרמוס אותו.
זה יהיה,
הוא האמין.
הוא האמין שלבון
נתן את ההוראה
מכיוון שהוא היה שראוי בקסמו של דיאן,
בקסמו של בנימין גיבלי
בימין ביבי
מפקד חיל המודיעין לרוז.
לפני מותו הוא אמר שהוא יכתוב את זה. על ספר
הספר לא פוגשות.
זה
אימו של
אחד,
נתלים בכאב
תושבת. בהמשך
נהגתי לרוץ יקיריו באר שבע.
אתה שמעת את השופט,
נכון?
תוכל לספר לנו איזשהו
איזושהי פי זאת המאך אני
תפקידך. כישופים
זה אני חושב שזה היה התפקיד.
המענה ביותר
ואחראי ביותר
שהיה לי בחיי
עומד לפנייך. נאשם
יש לך זומם בשבילו רבע שעה,
אבל ברווח השעה הזאת. השופט קובע את גורלו
אם נותן לו מעשיו,
מתי לה לעבור את בתו לכל ימי חייו,
או שהוא מסתפק בקנס
ויהיה
על כל פסק דין.
חשבתי
וחשבתי על זה גם שנים אחר כך
בדקתי איפה טעיתי.
מאוד נהניתי מזה.
אני מספר לך, לא לו פסקי דין
שבהם צדקתי ו בהם הייתי
היה אור לגויים.
אני אספר לך מקרה שטעיתי.
השם עמנואל זמיר אומר לך משהו?
כל שירי החליל והחליל עילית.
הוא היה עובר במעברות ומלמד את הילדים שירה ישראלי.
הוא היה מעורב בתאונות דרכים.
אגב, כשופט אז לא היו חלוקת תפקידים עכשיו, שגם בהוצאה לפועל
וגם בפלילי וגם באזרחי וגם מדיני שכירות,
ואז גם היה חקירה ציבורית. מוות של כל מי שמת
בדרך לא טבעית.
כשהייתי שופט באילת, וכשאמרתי את המשפטים בצהריים
ביום האחרון
החליפו איתו דקורציה, תלו את דיג לצה ל,
השוטרים הוחלפו במים
במשטרה הצבאית, ואני לבשתי מדים. הייתי שופט צבאי
באותו יום,
היקום
ויהיה.
הייתי חייב לשלול את הרישיון שלו. עצמי שעולה.
הוא אמר לפני
לא חשוב, שאני
אהבתי מאוד את השירה שלו.
הוא אומר לי תראה, אני עובד משרד החינוך
ואני נוסע למעברות.
אני נוסע ליישובים המרוחקים,
אני מלמד את הילדים שירה ישראלי.
אני מלמד אותם
נגינה בחליל.
אני מלמד אותם לאהוב את השירים, האישורים של ארץ ישראל.
אם אתה סולל לי את הרישיון,
אני לא אוכל לנסוע לשם. משרד החינוך לא יממן לי
מונית
ואז
אתה מעניש אותי. אבל
אני יושב בבית, אבל אתה מאמין שניתן בישראל,
ואני
תודה רב שהייתי צריך וחייב לשלול את הרישיון שלו.
הושפעתי מאוד מדבריו
ולא שאלתי.
שלושה חודשים אחרי נהרג בתאונת דרכים.
לא סלחתי לעצמי.
אז היום
שלא שלמתי לו יותר.
השופט יכול ליצור.
סיפרת לנו ששימשת
לחמש קדנציות
כראש עיריית באר שבע.
איך זה להיות ראש עיר?
כור היתוך,
קיבוץ גלויות.
כן.
נסעתי על זה הרצאה
ביום עיון באוניברסיטת בר אילן.
אחר כך פרסמו את זה בספר
השם. היום
כור היתוך או סיר לחץ?
בא אלינו הרבה, הרבה עליות שקלטנו אותם.
המטרה היתה
לחבר את האנשים.
אני חושב שהתעלמתי בזה. תרומה אני כן.
אנשי עדות המזרח.
יוצר צופה ניסוח
רובי בשר ובשר.
הם לא יתייחסו ל בהסתייגות
כשליח המימסד,
ולכן הייתה לי הידברות עם כולם
ולא היו פעם בעיות של הפליטה
בזמן מאורעות ואדי סאליב.
הייתי שופט,
ואני זוכר שישבתי בתיאטרון יורדים אישי. אני גם זוכר לזה. ההצגה הייתה,
ואז באים וקוראים לי
של הוראות ואדי סאליב
התפשטו גם לבאר
שבע
ושעירה.
ואם
כבר שרפו מכוניות
ומפקד המשטרה
חיכה לי
ולקח אותי לסיור,
לסיור וזזה, ראיתי יהודי ניצול שואה
שפותח כאן חנות.
הוא היה חייב.
לא הכרתי אותו קודם.
פרצו את החנות שלו
וראיתי אותו עומד על יד
הקיר של החנות,
מטיח את ראשו בקיר וצועק
יידיש
אין פוגרום.
אני חושב שזה היה הדבר
שהניע אותי
לעבור
עבודה ציבורית ולא להיות שופט.
מאוד אהבתי את התפקיד,
קורא מהפך בארץ ישראל
יחסית.
איך
ב
תראה, לא התרגשתי.
אף פעם
לא הייתי פוליטיקאי במפלגה,
הייתי
תמיד מבודד.
הקפדתי כל השנים האלה לחדש את רישיון עורכי הדין.
עורך הדין שלי
ערוך לאפשרות שמחר מדיחים אותי,
כי את יודעות יש בו ראית
כלום.
עץ שאינו נותן צל ועליו
ראוי שייקרא
שבעה. בחרנו בך.
איפה הג'ובים?
איפ?
תניחי את גביית מיסים.
איפה מכרזים?
איפה ג'ובים, איפה פקידים?
לא עמדתי בציפיות האלה ולכן
להיות במזכירות המפלגה. בשבילי זה היה הקרמטוריום.
ולכן בקדנציה השלישית
עזבתי את המפרט, לא?
ויצאתי לבחירות
אישיות
נגד כל המפלגות
ו בשתי הקדנציות האחרונות
הייתי בבית. לא התפוצצו לי מוקשים
בתוך העיר,
זה יהיה.
היתה לי גישה פתוחה
האנשים
מעדות המזרח. שחר, שהייתה טיפוח
חשוב אליהם,
היה יהודי
שמתקן נעליים לו שם
למטה לי נעליים ויש לה ברחוב קרן קימת
מתחת עץ
ואת לי נעליים של בדואים.
מוצע עליי עם אשתו. הייתה מביאה לו אוכל, יושבים
מתחת לעץ, אוכלים בבית
למישהו מהמפלגה עשה הפעם
כמו תמיד, בעיות.
הוא תפס אותו בבית הקפה,
אבל לא. תשמע,
אני סנדרה
הבדואים, מוריד נוהל, אומר לתקן. אני מתקן, אבל שואלים אותי מי אתה
ולמה מראש העיר שיושב שם
הוא מאנשייך.
אם אתה תפגע באיש הזה, אני ארצח אותך.
ויהו היה ביהודי זקן פרימיטיבי, מתקן נעליים
באיסור חג של פסח ובלי שוחק של סוכות
הוא היה לובש חליפה,
בא אליי להגיד לחג שמח,
שותה קפה,
רוצה מהכיסים שלו פוסט לא חלבי ויש כלים מלוחים, ושם
אומר לך שמח
הוא הולך.
הוא הרגיש את עצמו קרוב למימסד.
לא הייתה הנגשת מיקוח
טוב, כמובן, חושב
היה זמן שלא ראו בי חלק.
כן
מהממסד. השביל נזיר הוא מימש טייפ שנזכר
קוויזלינג
לדכא את הרב.
ההתקוממות של עדות המזרח.
אבל מהר באוצר
אנחנו יושבים כאן, בחדר, בחדרי, ככה
ואני רואה כאן
ודוחה
אוסף נפלא, תלוי של סוגי
חרבות
או
שברי אותו. כידון אינני יודעת איך לכנות אותם.
האם תוכל לספר לנו את האזמל? כחלל. זו האהבה שלי.
יש לי עשרות.
זה הנכדים. כבר תודה.
חלקו אותם.
אני שם. כאן רק את הדברים שמסמלים למה שהוא.
אבל יש דברים
שמסיימים לי הרבה,
אבל אני לא סולח.
הייתי פעם
בביקור
שנבע
כחבר הנהלת
אור
אצל מנכ ל הו רי
מקס ברוד
הוא הקים את אור.
הוא הפך לא, הוא לא הקים, אבל הוא לקח את זה לידיים.
הוא היה
אלוף משנה בצבא האמריקאי
החל הכיבוש
שהיה
הרב הצבאי הראשי. תהיו
הייתי אצלו
והייתי צריך להעריך את הדרכון. נתתי לה את הדרקון.
הוא גילה שיש לי גם הולדת, עשה חפלה גדולה,
עוגה גדולה.
והוא
מגיש לקראב
ועליו שלושה סכינים
לחתוך
אלה שלושה פדיונות
להציל
שקצינים בכירים
של חיל האוויר
של חיל השריון
ועוד חיים
עם צלבי כרס.
ואני עמדתי והיד שלי ראתה.
ואז אשתי באה וראתה מזי מיד את
הסכין וחתכתי את העוגה.
את הדמיונות האלה אני לא יכול לתלוש. את צדקת.
עכשיו אתה רוצה לדעת על הפיגיונות? אוקיי.
זוכרת פורשים צרפתית?
העוזר שלי בעירייה ששירת במילואים,
הוריד
בלשכתו של ראש עיריית
חיפה.
אני לא אספר לך לכולם. לכל אחד יש סיפור.
אני אקח את הדבר הזה.
חבר טוב שלי,
ידיד נפש
זו ניגשו אחר
אלוף משנה.
הוא
הקים את הצבא המודרני בחווה.
זו התמונה שלו.
טוב,
תודה.
בתום התרגיל
קיסר חווה
היי, נסה להשיג,
תנשק אותו בהם
במצח,
ונתנו במתנה את הדבר.
כן,
כזה שאהב
זה ראש העיר יהיה גור אריה יהודה של חמש.
ויש כאן נצרה.
אני פותח. או שלום.
ויש לי חבר,
ואת זה
זו למשוך המת. אני במצב
כן,
איזו אחרת
הכי יקרה
במערכה. קליף?
כן?
אפשר לשאול אותך, מר אליהו נביא.
מה מעשיך עליי?
טוב,
את אלי. קודם כל,
אני כבר עברתי את ה
זה יגר.
למזלי,
השכל שלי אומר
אני חושב, אני מקבל אולי
התרשמת אחרת
ואני ממשיך לעבוד.
יש פסוק בתהילים?
העובדים הסוציאליים נוהגים להשתמש בעוד תשליכי די לדזי. כלומר,
ככלות כוחי, אבל זמני.
ויש באותו ספר תהילים פסוק שלדעתי יותר חשוב.
אל תשליכי. אני מלפניך.
ורוח קוד שלך.
אל תיקח
ממני.
כל עוד
שהמוח פועל,
יותר קל לשאת את הירידה הגופני.
ואני ממשיך לעבוד.
לפני שנה
הוצאתי ספר מחקר בשטח
ש
סוגרי
סוגיות מקראיות בראייה דורות.
רוצה לתת לי אל?
כן.
בעוד שלושה חודשים יצא הוצאת על שלידו קצת מעריב
סיפורים
ערביים
לעונה
הבאה.
אני מתכוון,
כן. לתת
בבית התרבות ואומר
כן.
שמי נור על האיסלם.
שש עד שמונה הרצאות
וכבר מבקשים ממני לתת
בסדר בבית יד לבנים בבאר שבע,
בכל הניירות האלה. שאטרח לסלק מעל השולחן.
אנחנו הולכים על שולחן העבודה שלי,
ואני מתעסק איתם.
וטוב לי
כי יש לי אישה
שמחזיקה אותי
ומטפח את אותי.
ישבתי ועשיתי חשבון
כשאני
שני מיליון
ו
אלף פעם
אמרתי לה בוקר
טוב כשהתעלפתי.
הנההיא.
אני
רוצה להודות לך.
חן חן
אל
סיפור נפלא.
כשאומרים למי תודה ולמי המלכה
לעושה המלכה.
לא
הודות לך. לא צריך להגזים,
יודע, לא עשיתי לו טובה לאף אחד. אני
אני בטוחה. אבל
העשייה שלך
נתנה צבע וגוון בתרומה
לכל מה שנעשה כאן
ולכל הדבר הזה שאנחנו כולנו חלק ממנו במדינת ישראל המתחדשת.
אני רוצה להודות אני
רוצה
לסיים
ופסוק מפלאפי הערבות
לפני כן אני רק אסיים את בירכתי
תודות לך
ו לראייתך ולברך את שניכם
ב
שפע של העשייה.
בכל זאת, בבריאות טובה.
תודה,
זה יהיה
יש בקרבות
עסוק
כשאני אומר אותו לכל החברים שלי
לא עליך המלאכה לגמור
ולא אתה בן חורין להתבטל
ממנה.
תעשה דברים,
גארי מתי עוזר?
כשאתה לא תסיים אותם,
גם כשאתה יודע שאתה
עוד מעט
תפסיק לפעול.
אין נפקא בן חורין
לאיבות אל ממנה
זה
אני ממשיך לעשות במלאכה
כל אחד.
תודה,
קשה
לדעת.
הנשיא יצחק נבון,
ראש הממשלה
מנחם בגין,
שר החוץ האמריקני
סיירוס מממ
שמעון פרס,
עזר ויצמן
בוטרוס ראלי.
לימים מזכיר היום
זהו
מהמקור. ב
היה מקור בעיריית באר שבע.
כן, זה אני.
ואז
כולם הלכו,
ברור לי הנביא נשאר.
אני
עשרים
שעות לא